fox news host laura ingram or ingraham  take your pick who is very much against  communism and socialism and his four  free markets  is now calling for the nationalization  of disney and when republicans they get  back into power  athel and disney need to understand one  thing  everything will be on the table your  copyright and trademark protection your  special status within certain states and  even your corporate structure itself  it's almost like they don't even  understand  that they don't believe the things they  say they believe it as long as it's  convenient and as soon as disney does  something she doesn't like  she goes full communist and says the  government  should take over disney